si usted es mujer y tiene ciertos
problemas con sus órganos reproductivos
su médico puede recomendarle una
histerectomía robótica para quitarle el
útero
sus órganos reproductivos incluyen su
vagina
cuello del útero
útero
trompas de falopio
y ovarios
puede necesitar histerectomía robótica
si tiene una de las siguientes
condiciones o enfermedades
sangrado uterino fuerte o constante
anemia y dolor pélvico
cáncer en el útero
cuello del útero
u ovarios
tumores fibroides no cancerígenos en su
útero
o flacidez o deslizamiento de su útero
en su vagina por debilidad o lesión en
los músculos pélvicos y los ligamentos
uterinos
antes del procedimiento se colocará una
vía intravenosa o ive
usted puede recibir antibióticos por vía
intravenosa para disminuir la
posibilidad de infecciones
se le administrará anestesia general
se le insertará un tubo respiratorio por
la boca y en la tráquea para ayudarle a
respirar durante la operación
su cirujano realizará una pequeña
incisión cerca de su ombligo
insertará un tubo plástico llamado
Puerto
se bombeará gas dióxido de carbono a su
abdomen a través de este Puerto el gas
inflará su abdomen lo que le dará al
cirujano más espacio para ver y mover
las herramientas quirúrgicas
después de inflar su abdomen se
insertará una cámara de alta definición
en este puerto
su cirujano realizará incisiones
adicionales del puerto para instrumentos
robóticos así como para instrumentos
usados por los asistentes que se
encuentran junto al paciente
un asistente insertará todas las
herramientas robóticas por estos puertos
A diferencia de los instrumentos
laparoscópicos estándar estas
herramientas pueden rotar 360 grados y
tienen mayor flexibilidad que la muñeca
humana
Sentado en una consola especial su
cirujano operará los brazos robóticos y
la cámara con controles tipo joystick Y
pedales a pie
una computadora traducirá los
movimientos exactos de los dedos de su
cirujano en movimientos precisos de las
herramientas quirúrgicas
a la vez un sistema de visión de alta
definición ofrecerá una vista
estereoscópica aumentada en tres
dimensiones del área quirúrgica
dependiendo de su condición puede tener
una histerectomía parcial en la que su
cirujano le quitará el útero pero dejará
el cuello del útero
las trompas de falopio y los ovarios en
su lugar
si tiene una histerectomía total su
cirujano le quitará el cuello del útero
junto al útero
si tiene una histerectomía radical su
cirujano puede además quitarle las
trompas de falopio los ovarios
la parte superior de su vagina
así como los tejidos cercanos tales como
los nódulos linfáticos pélvicos
al final del procedimiento se cerrarán
las pequeñas incisiones con puntos de
sutura grapas pegamento quirúrgico o con
vendajes de cierre
después del procedimiento se le retirará
el tubo respiratorio y se le trasladará
al área de recuperación para controlarlo
le darán medicamentos para el dolor si
fuese necesario usted puede continuar
recibiendo antibióticos por vía
intravenosa le pueden dar el alta del
hospital el mismo día o un día después
del procedimiento